My sister flew in a week ago,
and all she's been asking me to do is make her an apple crumble,
and even though she's avoiding sugar and desserts right now,
she said she would make an exception if I made her one.
She didn't have to tell me that twice,
and I decided to make her one.
Cut up some Granny Smith apples,
combined that with brown sugar,
cornstarch, and some lemon.
Set those aside while I got started on my crumble,
which was just some flour,
brown sugar, a pinch of salt,
baking powder, some melted butter.
Give that a stir until it was all crumbly
before spreading it all over my apples
and baking it for about 30 minutes.
In the meantime, I got started on my crema glaze.
Combine some heavy cream, milk, vanilla,
a pinch of salt, and some sugar.
Let that warm up on the stove
and then tempered my egg yolks with it
before putting it back on the stove and letting it thicken.
I strained it through a fine mesh strainer
and then placed it in the fridge so it was nice and cold
with the warm apple pie. That was done,
I pulled it out of the oven,
and this made my kitchen smell so good.
I put some of my vanilla cream down,
the apple crumble on top. She kept coming back until all of it was gone.